OK, so,
here are a few things
you might have missed
while watching the movie.
Let's go.
One is the moment
that you see Cherokee Bill
and Trudy Smith
walking past the train.
Take a moment
and read the name
of that train.
C. A. Boseman.
Yes.
Chadwick Boseman.
Rest in power, king.
In the town,
in Redwood, you know,
if you look on the street
and you see the names
of the shops,
you know,
what James did is start
to put family and friends,
and their names
became the shops.
So, there's a Carter
and Carter general store.
You know
who the Carters are.
It's named
after Jay-Z and Beyoncé.
And it's
an interesting thing.
When I was naming those,
I was literally giving out
stores like a dictator,
calling up people.
"What's your middle name?"
"We'll name that store
after you."
And I called Jay,
and I was like,
"Jay, what name
goes with Carter?"
He's like,
"What do you mean?"
"What name
goes with Carter?"
You know,
Jay's voice is kind of high,
it's aspirational.
And he went,
"Only one name
goes with Carter."
"What name's that?"
He went, "Carter."
"Carter and Carter."
I was like…
"Carter and Carter
General Store."
There's a JL
Savings and Loan,
and James Lassiter
is the producer.
He's a great producer
in Hollywood,
people know him very well.
I wanted to have the bank,
but I didn't think about it,
you know,
when I had that idea.
When we go to Douglastown,
and Nat Love is riding in,
you see a man
taking a picture
of another man in a coffin
and you see
the name Rex Mills.
And during COVID,
I did an Instagram
murder mystery
that starred Jay-Z,
Ellen Pompeo,
Tiffany Haddish,
Jesse Williams,
Sterling K. Brown,
Cynthia Erivo, Zazie Beetz,
and it ended
with Morgan Freeman
saying that he's Rex Mills.
I am Rex Mills.
And you see Rex Mills
in The Harder They Fall
and Morgan Freeman
plays Rex Mills.
There's just so many, like,
little things like that.
Something else
you might have missed?
I don't know
if you missed it,
but it's just
a fun fact that…
I happen to walk around
with this thing
all the time.
Here we are,
in the real world,
and this is my cup.
This is also Nat Love's cup.
And this is the cup
we drink out of in the film,
throughout the film.
Never known you to touch it.
Only after I kill a man.
I mean, there's a huge
Easter egg in this film
that I am not going
to tell you what the egg is.
It's huge.
And it's where
I place music over film.
I'm not going to tell you
what it is,
but I'll tell you the song.
The song is "Blackskin Mile"
by Cee-Lo,
But I know there's
Something better outside
And it's…
It's…
It plays at the end
and kind of…
It kind of joins and moulds
the storylines of Rufus Buck
and Nat Love when he's bent
over Jim Beckwourth,
and Cherokee Bill
when he faces Cuffee.
And the song speaks of his…
his…
his state of mind.
But there's a huge,
huge, huge Easter egg
in that song.
It's a code, and…
I'll leave that to you guys
to find out.